We're back with our world lead now.
We learned today that President Biden
intends to travel to Poland
later this month to mark one year
since Russia's brutal war on Ukraine
Poland is right next to Ukraine.
Of course,
officials in war ravaged
Ukraine think that today's fresh
nationwide barrage of Russian
missiles could be the precursor
to Putin's dreaded spring offens
Ukraine claims
it has shot down
more than 85% of the incoming
missile fire still.
Ukrainian President
Volodymyr Zelensky
is intent on stepping up Ukraine
firepower with an official reque
to the Netherlands for F-16 figh
CNN's David
McKenzie is in the capital, Kiev
where running for shelter is onc
becoming a daily part of life.
Russian
forces left exposed on the froze
flatlands around
are one of the most deadly zones
of the eastern front.
Ukrainian artillery and drones
picking off the static targets.
Even pro-Russian sources
say they've taken heavy losses h
A missile, the Ukrainian foot pa
to the southern outskirts
of the heavily damaged town.
And they appear to be
taking some prisoners to this
These men identify themselves
as belonging to Russia's
155th Marine Brigade
to the north on the edges of Mah
Russian troops
advancing block by block
towards the city.
They've been inching forward for
taking heavy losses.
Ukrainian forces
desperate to deny Vladimir
Putin a symbolic victory
as the first anniversary of this
approaches.
Across a wide area in the east.
The Ukrainians detect
a buildup in Russian troops
and heavy weapons.
That could be a prelude
to a widely anticipated offensiv
But Ukrainian officials have tol
that in some areas,
their own troops are critically
short of munitions.
And throughout the country,
Russia launched its largest miss
barrage in months,
targeting Ukrainian
civilian infrastructure,
including this thermal plant
in De Dnipro.
The city of Zakariya
hit 17 times in one hour.
A Russian cruise missile
struck the power grid
of the immense power of the stri
throwing a car onto the roof of
The Opportu
we are group
knows that they are not humans.
Says the event of the Russians.
I don't know what they're thinki
when they're doing this.
When they press the buttons
and shell civilians too far to
the Ukrainians
say they brought down
61 of the 70 missiles fired
Yes enough to limit
damage to the power supply.
As sirens blared.
Thousands of people in the capit
Kiev took to the subway shelters
to run businesses and take class
It's a well-practiced routine
budget mess up since mid-Decembe
Alas,
the children may not be comforta
says teacher Elena.
But since September,
the alarms have been so frequent
that they've got used to classes
in the metro that she facade thi
movement in the skies above
the war against Russia's
missiles and drones goes on
And those attacks continue into
There's been several reports
from Ukrainian forces
that there have been drone attac
in the south and also threats
here in the capital, Kiev.
They've asked people to stay ind
stay on the ground
as those air sirens go off to ke
You can be sure.
With President Biden
coming to the region
in the coming weeks,
that President Zelensky will con
pushing the US and others
to get more sophisticated weapon
to push out
any advance of the Russians
and the Eastern Front, including
possibly those F-16s. Jake.
David McKenzie
in Kiev, Ukraine, thank you so m